de las cenizas de la segunda guerra
mundial en el contexto de la guerra fría
nació la otan el 4 de abril de 1949 se
firmó el tratado del atlántico norte en
washington dc este fue un pacto militar
pero también una alianza de valores
compartidos para contrarrestar la
amenaza que representaba la unión
soviética
si hay algo inevitable en el futuro es
la voluntad de los pueblos del mundo por
la libertad y la paz
a lo largo de los años la otan ha
resistido innumerables tormentas tanto
en lo interno como la retirada militar
de francia en 1959 y externamente como
la crisis de los misiles cubanos en 1962
o la crisis de los misiles europeos en
1979 desde su fundación la lista de
miembros creció de los 12 originales a
30 países el artículo 5 de la carta de
la otan dice que un ataque armado contra
un miembro es un ataque contra todos la
primera y única vez que se invocó este
artículo fue el día después de los
ataques del 11 de septiembre contra los
eeuu los miembros de la otan se unieron
y fueron a la guerra con eeuu en
afganistán para luchar contra al qaeda y
los talibanes pero recientemente la otan
una crisis existencial cuando donald
trump amenazó con retirarse de la
alianza
ahora con joe biden en la casa blanca la
perspectiva ha cambiado drásticamente y
ha dicho tiene a la otan en su adn ha
llamado a la otan un deber sagrado para
eeuu y ha prometido que eeuu se
mantendrá firmemente comprometido con la
defensa colectiva de la otan defense la
otan buscará nuevamente la seguridad de
que puede contar con el apoyo de su
miembro más poderoso eeuu